here we go
[Music]
background I'm talking Taekwondo jujitsu
of the stuff
finally God damn I'm myself
[Music]
thank you
mosquito
that's what you get
you laugh at me you die
Douglas Ephraim bin Lazer Menachem
Harris
Douglas
Harris okay just really give it a good
thing
I put my hands on your [__] Ty
yeah okay see see now
foreign
potato chips and eat every last one of
them
yeah that's what that's really that's
just [__] on me and don't leave any
toilet paper
is that what this is
are you the big dog yeah I'm the big dog
I'm gonna be a little [__] I'm the big
dog how big
how big
well know what I do when I walk to my
job I duck cause it's a big ass
inflatable gorilla holding a banana
that's getting blown all over the place
that's right
don't nobody here to watch eyes accept
me I mean you only season one holder
Douglas Ephraim Ben laser manahim Harris
that was so good too I'm sorry
Douglas Ephraim
okay Douglas Ephraim bin manachim Harris
battle
our time
um this is PornHub
[Music]
you're my best friend oh my God it's the
best day of my life I don't care How It
Ends I want to get your Hub but you
still got your dick
let's just push it to the side
oh my God why of course
I got it look at that I'm using
everything like that I'm sorry I got it
127.
don't worry I know this guy and he won't
even know that he's committing trees
until he does
there was one time where uh the condom
popped because I put my body cares about
your little pee pee there's a situation
with this girl named dirty Jay but at
this time I wasn't uh
take Gretchen Palmer to be able
come on man you know how hard
the hell out of here man yo yo George
what's up with you here with the
tightest rap game on the street what's
good with you babe what's good with you
B it was really good baby huh what's
good with you man
it's called Soul gazing
stare into my soul
and I'll stare into yours come in you
are not my wife okay oh that's it
it's all about the man on the grill I
think I'm in the right hand because you
look like you know
[__] God damn it all right
I don't like it in the ass either
hey man what you doing hey man relax I'm
just getting some nuts
sh
[Applause]
H I promise you on everything
let's keep one keep on
it's real this is for real guys yeah
I'm sorry guys I'm nervous was that for
real yes
I can smell Kevin's spot
it's not you can't smell it oh my God
all we gotta do is get in the car
he switched it up oh oh I want the other
guy back I gotta wait for six more
people to come
that's it
I
can't do this oh my God
my aunt dresses up her cats
okay now you can't keep a secret
okay you're in like a gay thesaurus and
I'm I'm I'm in a regular talking not not
that anything is wrong with this the
source I want to see a gay thesaurus
your client Armando's there I find that
out cause Dash told me and her dad
called me a [__] shut up sonny we're
not doing this right now
[__] scared me
[Music]
too hard
[Applause]
[Music]
listen to me
hurry up
but we are all dead
this is gonna be it doesn't it you hurry
up and fix that help I said stop hitting
me
guys
you ready I'm going to hit I touch it
box is ready got that NWA song ready for
your player I don't like their group too
sassy
you can't
I love you
Santa's close is gonna get Dave I love
you
I'm not gonna do it four hundred dollars
he's trying to kiss me for real [__]
four hundred dollars he's trying to kiss
me for real y'all
get right in there all right come on
let's go come on let's go [__] what else
looks like you're coming in
[Music]
thank you
you remember Robbie weird it from uh
from high school no the guy who went to
the prom with Mrs Herbert The Librarian
remember the guy that brought his dog to
the prom the guy who took his pair of
the prom the guy who used to eat the
hamburgers out of the trash the guy
got a hole in the back the guy who
believed that men could pee out their
butt they got to try to sell dental
floss to everybody in the cafeteria the
guy the guy that the men could get
pregnant if they held it but if I could
but if I could just take
maybe this weekend I can do
the guy that got raped by our science
teacher remember Mr McMahon had that big
case the guy who used to brush his teeth
in the water fountain the boy with the
breasts the the boy with the baboon ass
no remember that day he accidentally
showed his ass in gym class it was real
red they called him baboon ass
almost killed this energy what are you
talking about we're fine
nah you are a terrible drop
how do I get your attention make a bird
call go home
[Applause]
mom did US did I eat all the milk
because he didn't get any nutrients she
just shut up did I drink the milk too
fast
come here
it's out
it's so awkward
awkward my man you better back the [__]
up back the [__] up before I [__] you
these Fists
fish
damn
mackerel
[Applause]
who does that
I don't know if I'm a can of paint what
part out of the closet don't you
understand we're not out
I Calvin
me human
communicate big man
no play
no